[Music]
Yeah right Chris well you know I met ray
several times he's a super good guy
liked him a lot and I'm glad he's out
there doing it in this sense I'm not
skeptical in a cynical way like I hope
that those singularity people are wrong
no I hope they're right I hope he does
it I hope he lives forever because that
means I may have a shot at it whatever
that would even mean living forever okay
and so when people like Ray say to me
Sherman strimmer now you want to live
500 years a thousand years you know it's
like listen I'm 63 just get me to like
80 without you know my brain going crazy
and I'm losing my mind and Alzheimer's
and senility and you know get me to a
hundred without cancer and you know give
me 120 without being bedridden you know
just one step at a time one problem at a
time
that's how progress really happens
incrementally slowly not this grin let's
aim for utopia
I mean aim for it fine but but just take
it one step at a time you know cancer
you know there's like 50 different
cancers that kill people just tackle em
one by one heart disease Alzheimer's and
senility just solved those problems and
that because we know that the human body
is so complex that if you live to 150 or
200 there may be other things that
happen we don't even know yet I mean
most people 500 years ago had no idea
about Alzheimer's other than the handful
of people that seem to have lost their
memories but you know now we realize
because most of so many of us live that
long okay so that's the problem with
with that is it's too utopian in their
thinking just incremental steps and then
second um my my skeptical my skeptical
alarms always go off when the chief
proponent of an idea that's gonna be the
next big thing always says it's in our
generation you know every religious
leader and cult leader in history has
always said it's going to happen now in
our generation all the way back to Jesus
who said there are some standing here
before me now who will not see the end
of time before I return okay so and
we're still waiting you know so that you
know when race is gonna happen in you
know 2040 it's it within our lifetime
ray what if it's 21 40
I know you're gonna you're doing all the
blood cleansing on but you're not gonna
make it you know like another century
now and and and it but even so what if
it's 31:59 3140 a thousand years from
now I mean that's possible but you know
you and I aren't gonna be here to enjoy
you know why sell it like it's got to
happen in my lifetime because that
always to me seems like you're just
tickling that part of the brain that
religions like to tap in that that sort
of egocentric it's all about me and I
want to continue on in the future
I get that of course I do too but but
all the more reason we should be
skeptical when the idea on the table
being offered to us is feels too good to
be true it almost always is not always
but but usually and so and there's
hardly anything bigger than offering
Imbert our immortality or they afterlife
because good so here's the problem
we are all aware that death is real
because we see all around us 100 billion
people have lived before us they're all
gone not one of them has come back not
even Jesus in my opinion but that's a
different video and yet you can't you
cannot conceive of what it's like to be
dead because if I asked you picture
yourself dead what do you see you know
most people say well I see you know
myself there at the funeral in the
coffin and you know my loved ones are
you know hopefully grieving and they're
right no you wouldn't see that you
wouldn't see anything because to see
anything you have to be conscious to
conceive of anything you have to be a
sentient being you have to be conscious
and if you're dead you don't have any of
that you you're just really death is
just nothing and and the whole idea of
the afterlife is fairly new I mean the
ancient Hebrews their idea of the
afterlife was nothing you're just just
nothing you're just gone that's it
there's no place to go with angels and
flowers and whatever it's just nothing
you know all that was added on centuries
later and you know and probably for
socio-political reasons you know offer
the peasant something nice so that
they'll keep bill
our pyramids or whatever you know so you
know again we can't conceive of what
it's like to be dead yet we see it all
around us so this creates something of a
paradox that we have to resolve in our
minds most people resolve it by thinking
well I'm not actually gonna die I'm just
not gonna do it I'm gonna live forever
or I'm gonna accept Jesus or whatever
and I'm going to heaven yeah okay yeah
but what if you're wrong
that's you know it's not a it's not a
Pascal's wager where you could say well
I have nothing to lose and everything to
gain because which religion and their
version of the afterlife is the right
one which one you got to pick yeah well
the Christians we're the right ones yeah
well there's a billion Muslims who
disagree with you you know they don't
accept Jesus as a savior they don't
think he was even the Messiah or the Son
of God okay so now what you know that
and they believe just as strongly as you
do so what if your God is the wrong one
you're your version is the wrong theory
and they have the right one you picked
you wasted your all life investing on
this idea and you turned out to be wrong
why not jettison the whole idea entirely
and appreciate the here and now because
that's all we have whatever is in the
hereafter here and now is what we have
[Music]